no industry that's actually worked with
nepotism it's bollywood yeah yeah they
don't really seem to allow much else
yeah every faith yeah i guess but like
still the industry is like extremely
profitable everyone loves it the movies
are great and it's all
it's all nepotism and why why do you
think it can function that way i don't
know maybe acting is so easy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your [ __ ] mouth maybe maybe
acting is that easy oh explosion bust
falls over
[Laughter]
is there a bollywood scene that involves
a white guy that you and andrew can
interact
no the white guys are always like some
[ __ ] they're just terrible characters
every time
it's like squid games it's those mass
[ __ ]
no they just they try to speak hindi it
sounds so bad it's always brutal if you
were a white dude that grew up in delhi
spoke perfect hindi could you get cast
as like a bollywood actor like are there
any roles for you if you're like you
ain't related so no with those notes
you could have some role maybe somebody
side character but you're not gonna be a
little but uh veer wasn't related right
and he was able to do something yeah
veer got in and it does happen he says
it's possible but it just seems like
families have such a chokehold on it and
bollywood is such an integral like they
have a chokehold on entertainment movies
are like this is our escape we go watch
the movie we're done
three hours it's gonna be a fun story
like they're starting to make more like
realistic gritty kind of shows and i'm
curious to know how india
takes it and to me i almost look at it
as a sign what do you mean like so like
india that i grew up with
yeah that i grew up with was pure
escapism i'm gonna go watch fun rich
people beautiful colors india's
beautiful colors in general but like
happy stories it'll be melodramatic but
happy stories because life is hard yep
the good guy wins at the end like heroes
journey yeah we love the gritty because
our life is good like what do we need to
escape to oh so we want to feel
something real yeah because we're living
in we're living in a [ __ ] this is we
are the one percent yeah yeah whether we
like to admit it or not yeah you go to a
referee like a hero's journey as well
but i hear what you're saying there is
there's also
an industry for these kind of gritty
movies because there are people that
need to access those feelings where in
bollywood that was very rare i can think
i don't need to feel that [ __ ] i feel
one or two movies where the main
character died i'm sure there's more but
growing up the big ones and now i'm
starting to see more gritty kind of
bollywood movies and i'm wondering if
that's a sign of their economy getting
stronger well it's also excuse me
they've climbed out of the third world
and now they're like well you know we
want to see some of this there's people
who are like dude life is good what's
gonna marley and me i wanna see reality
yeah
yeah you see uh miss marvel
i haven't seen it yet oh you should
check it out i heard they'd be [ __ ]
on india and these pakistanis
i don't know about that but i mean
but it's like disney it's great and
netflix are coming to india they're not
going to compete with bollywood they're
going to say okay what's the method let
me bring a [ __ ] let me bring a thriller
let me bring something a little bit more
yeah netflix is trying to do bali like
trying to compete with bollywood but
they're doing it through
different shows grittier shows sadder
shows reality type [ __ ]
interesting yeah that's really that's an
interesting observation though like as a
country lifts itself out of destitute
poverty
it starts to
feel and relate to different things in
the art yeah like the art is always a
reflection i think marley me should be
the test i said that as a joke if you're
if you if your country likes marley and
me you're first world can you break down
more only me to anybody who hasn't seen
literally is like white family they
adopt a dog the dog gets old they got to
put it down end of the movie it's just
like we're sad our family dog died it's
old yeller but without babies yeah but
old yeller's sad because like real life
happens like nature takes over the dogs
decrepit it dies like this dog just got
old they got lumpy and they're like all
right go to sleep forever like that's
the whole movie so i think if you're as
a country it's like sad about this it's
like yeah you're doing pretty good yeah
any other country i can't believe you've
seen marley and me and not the godfather
what the [ __ ] is going on because i like
real movies but i like cinema yeah
because my life is you know my life is
hard that's what it is i don't want to
watch the godfathers too real that's
every day for me that was what flipped a
switch with me with bollywood in terms
of liking it because i was like oh i was
like it's so like surreal and it's so
ridiculous and i was like oh they want
to escape because they don't have my
cushy ass life in america so watch it
and don't expect the real [ __ ] the
reality or an action star like flipping
over an 18 wheeler i'm like that's so
[ __ ] stupid right they don't want
real real sucks yeah there's so many
people over there
so
give us give me escapism and then i
watch it with a different lens and i was
like oh we're just having fun this is
great yeah well when you go to your
place and you're playing like poppy
indian music and you're just like oh
yeah yeah i don't know what trendy is
think of marlin if like you went to utah
if you like they'd be like why are you
adopting this [ __ ] street dog
take our food
let's think the [ __ ] out of here that's
my ploy bro play that movie anywhere in
north korea you want to talk your dog
did you anybody in your family have a
dog
nah never mad street dogs and you just
looked in like yo get the [ __ ] away from
our food you know yeah that's
interesting i'm fascinated by cultures
that don't have pets okay like we live
in williamsburg right next to all these
hasidic jews hasidic jews don't have
pets i've never seen a city jew walking
a dog ever in my life they just don't
they just don't do it and why do you
think that i don't know i don't know
what the point is like but i think like
in china so many [ __ ] kids they don't
want like another thing to look after is
that what it is i i genuinely think that
is like you're a woman you have six kids
by the time you're like 25
do you really want a dog but you got to
think there's gotta be one woman that
has two kids and it's like oh yeah puppy
would be nice i think they think it'd be
nice i assume that they'd be nice but
they're like that's not the focus right
does the woman get a say i'm actually
asking and what in an orthodox community
does it in a saying what that and like
hey we're getting an outfit
is the woman the one being like oh i
don't want a dog i think if a man wants
a dog they're going to dog
i don't know duff i'm ignorant asking
this question i thought
more than anybody so
i don't think he'd have a single [ __ ]
clue i think it's like part of the
culture not to worship anything other
than muslims often don't have dogs oh
that's interesting is it uh why are we
going out of our way to feed this thing
do they have dogs in india like do they
have pets now if you're doing well you
have a dog and you love the [ __ ] out of
it but
a lot of people don't but muslims often
don't have dogs and it's like a
cleanliness thing i think i can see that
it's like a cultural
thing you're bringing in stuff from the
street yeah um
i don't like german shepherds it is a
it is a super
it is a super flex though when you think
about it yeah the idea like we have so
much there is such abundance in this
family yeah that we can take care of an
animal like you said that [ __ ] a while
ago and i've always thought about it the
like
like uh a flex is just waste yes yeah
yeah and apparently i this popped up the
other day on i was reading some [ __ ] it
was like high ceilings yeah high
ceilings but also like waste space the
american lawn it's the
yeah literally no not even nothing i
have room to not grow food gardens oh
yeah oh not only
is oh i could grow food that's
interesting i don't even need to grow
food this is just a vineyard here
imagine you got a garden like i'm doing
the work but i'm not growing food i'm
just growing flowers yeah you're just
throwing flowers botanical garden what a
waste dude people from other countries
must show up like wait you can't eat
none of this [ __ ] you have a dedicated
area to growing things you cannot eat
it's a food museum people pay to come
not eat to not eat to look at things
that are growing out of the ground yo
flowers are waste yeah yeah
flowers are wasted that's what i try to
tell my girl
that's why they love
[Music]
complete waste i'm having like high
moments right now but how interesting is
that like at least a [ __ ] tree
generates shade right which is life or
death yeah like also oxygen but like
literally shade in the [ __ ] desert or
hot that is life or death situation a
flower grows
six inches off the [ __ ] ground
right it offers no shade you cannot eat
it it is
it is a
a drain on a humanity
the fact that we give this to things as
gifts at least it looks pretty what
about the people who just get plants
and just fill up a whole studio
what about
show shade
oxygen leds